Háng thông tấn chương quân chương tiến cà sế ngã, ngày 3,5 năm đưa tình,
nước này đã tiến hành thay thế hàng loạt quan chương quân sự cấp cao,
trong đó có cuộc chưởng của phó bình và cuộc chưởng của ăn đi quân đổi.
Các quý định nhất sử được thông qua trong vụ nghĩ mở sợp lần thứ tảm của quân quủ nguyện trong đảng mà đồng chương tiến.
Dên xa ngày 2,5, giới sự chủ chi, của nhà lãnh đạo Kim Chương ngừng.
Cúng theo cà sế ngã, quân quủ nguyện đã đề bạ tình sấu chi vuy đần vệ các quân đoạn,
và điều đọc một số chính quyền, nhằm tăng cường kỳ lật tời bầu,
khuò hà cũng thả loạt biển phát duy trí, uống thế chính lượng và chính thạc của quân đổi,
cũng có sự ăn mởi trong lý vực khuò hà và công nghệ của phòng.
Đồng thấy này dễn thà sửa sửa của trong lễ hạ tuy tấu khu chục,
tại sự đón thảo chương chim, mình nhà lãnh đạo Kim Chương ngừng mô tả,
là tán nạn nghiêm trọc, bàn vi vàng tội không thể xuống khu,
ông yêu cầu sửa chữa thông hoàn tất chứ khu của nghị quan thị bán chương mừng đàn,
dự kiến phát sau.